et chaque d'elancourt n'ont pas tenu le
choc face à saint gratien
pourtant l'entamé chinoise était quasi
parfaite après dix minutes de jeu les
joueurs de benjamin ferran même deux
buts à zéro
le palais semblait avoir choisi son camp
au gymnase chastagner c'était sans
compter sur la défaillance physique élan
courtoise après la pause saint gratien
réduit les cartes sur un très mauvais
marquage des chocs avant de revenir au
score dans la foulée on a fait une bonne
première mi temps où sur l'impact
physique on était bien et puis après
physiquement il avait on a lâché
et puis on sent monter son plus fort que
moi l'impact physique
mais là notre jeu d'un et s'est disloqué
vous avez beaucoup dit on était
peut-être un peu juste
les deux joueurs là c'est leur premier
match de la saison en fin de rencontre
les élans courtois au courage légalistes
à trois partout et dans la dernière
minute de jeu un nouveau boulevard
ouvert par la défense jaune et blanche
offre la victoire à saint gratien
score final 4 3 une première défaite en
championnat qui ne remet pas en cause
des objectifs des chocs ce finir parmi
les quatre premiers ont joué les payer
ouais